Thomas jazzombeck ist jetzt der erste
Trainer der hier das Wort ergreift zur
Beratung der Fraktion der Antrag CDU CSU
Technologie Agenda neue Energien Rolle
der Wissenschaft in der Bundesregierung
stärken wir reden über Hilfen für
diejenigen die es brauchen wir reden
über sparen und wir reden darüber dass
aus anderen Staaten zu beziehen aus den
USA per LNG und woher auch immer meine
Damen und Herren das was ich in dieser
Diskussion der letzten Monate vermisse
ist die Frage wie wir auch mit
Technologie dieses Problem angehen
können
wir sind
wir sind wir sind eine ingenieursnation
in Deutschland und wir haben viele
Beiträge geleistet um am Ende die
Menschheit auch nach vorne zu bringen es
beginnt mit dem Buchdruck es geht über
die Glühbirne das Telefon das
Periodensystem Straßenbahn Auto die
Relativitätstheorie der erste Computer
alles Deutsche Erfindungen und sogar die
Goldbären zitiert das Handelsblatt als
eine fundamentale Erfindung und meine
Damen und Herren warum sollten unsere
Ingenieurinnen und Ingenieure unsere
Forscher und Wissenschaftler nicht in
der Lage sein auch für diese Krise
Lösungen zu finden und es gibt sie es
gibt Reife Technologien die in unseren
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen an unseren
Universitäten an unseren Hochschulen für
angewandte Wissenschaften sind und ich
vermisse
die Stimme der Forschungsministerin ich
habe sie in diesem ganzen Kontext nicht
gehört ich vermisse die Ausgaben von
diesen rund 300 Milliarden Euro sind 0
für Technologie vorgesehen alles was Sie
heute tun mit der wasserstoffinitiative
und anderem sind Dinge die wir in der
corona-krise als Budget zur Verfügung
gestellt haben 9 Milliarden alleine für
das Thema Wasserstoff und deshalb meine
Damen und Herren als service-opposition
bieten wir Ihnen heute mal an wie eine
Strategie aussehen sollte diese sich zu
eigen machen müssen wie ich finde wir
brauchen dringend eine technologieagenda
wir brauchen erstens eine
wissenschaftsbasierte schonungslose
Analyse damit muss es beginnen wir
brauchen zum zweiten eine Initiative für
Schnellläufer was können wir kurzfristig
erreichen Technologie heute aus dem
Labor in die Fabrik und wenn es zum
Beispiel Solarzellen sind auf die
Häuserdächer bringen wir brauchen
drittens ein strategischen Ansatz in
dieser ganzen Diskussion wird ständig
darüber geredet wie wir durch diesen
Winter kommen aber vereinfacht
gesprochen meine Damen und Herren womit
wollen wir in fünf Jahren heizen darauf
müssen wir heute die Antwort finden und
auch die richtigen Entscheidungen
treffen und es geht auch um eine
langfristige Perspektive die
langfristige Perspektive sind Themen wie
zum Beispiel Kernfusion wurde der ein
oder andere sagt das ist Zukunftsmusik
sicherlich wird die Kernfusion uns nicht
in den nächsten fünf oder zehn Jahren
hier ein energiebeitrag leisten aber
heute müssen die Entscheidungen
getroffen werden wenn heute nicht die
Entscheidungen für diese Technologie
getroffen werden wo wir gut sind wir
haben zwei spannende Start-ups in
Darmstadt in München wir haben
Wendelstein x wir haben ita wenn heute
nicht die Entscheidung getroffen werden
hier auch zu investieren dann werden die
Talente woanders hingehen in Silicon
Valley nach China und die Technik wird
für uns nicht erschließbar sein
und ich will das auch mal auf diesen
mittelfristigen Zeitraum etwas
konkretisieren drei bis fünf Jahre was
kann man denn da schaffen und wir haben
ja gestern schon über e-fuels und andere
Dinge geredet wenn wir mit den
Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern unsere aos insbesondere
diskutieren sagen die immer wir brauchen
globale energiepartnerschaften wir haben
so was auch schon begonnen im BMBF als
wir noch in der Regierung waren wir
müssen das jetzt skalieren und das
bedeutet ein Projekt wie beispielsweise
in Patagonien wo tatsächlich am Ende 550
Liter e-fuels in den nächsten Jahren im
industriellen Maßstab gemacht werden
übrigens wird Fördergeldern des BMW i
aus der alten Periode
das sind industrieller Maßstab skalierte
Technologie die Dinge die wir brauchen
und war es der Beitrag der Forschung
ganz einfach es gibt zum Beispiel
Start-ups die gerade auf dieser falling
walls-konferenz sich präsentiert haben
die mit neuen Verfahren deutlich
effizienter messanol aus grüner Energie
erzeugen können was die Basis am Ende
dafür ist genau diese diese Energie nach
Deutschland zu bekommen und wo wir
wirklich ein impact machen können und
können vielleicht aus diesen 550 Litern
e-fuse dieser Anlage zwei oder drei
Milliarden machen und das ist der
Beitrag den die Forschung her leisten
muss frau Ministerin wir haben ihn in
der letzten Sitzungswoche ein Konzept
gemacht wie sie ein Rettungsschirm für
die Wissenschaft ausbreiten sie hatten
das nicht auf dem Schirm sie sind an dem
Tag der Debatte darauf eingegangen das
war schlau wir haben in der letzten
Sitzungswoche ein Konzept vorgelegt wie
sie 200 Euro an die Studierenden
ausbringen können da haben sie viel zu
spät auf uns gehört deshalb werden sie
nicht ersten ersten fertig jetzt folgen
Sie unserem Konzept das ist auch schlau
deshalb appelliere ich an sie
seien sie auch hier klug nehmen Sie
unseren Ball dieser technologieagenda
auf wir können diese Krise nicht lösen
ohne neue Technologie und dort müssen
wir investieren wir müssen es
wissenschaftsbasiert machen und wir
müssen die Köpfe unserer Forscherinnen
und Forscher nutzen um aus dieser Krise
zu kommen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege bevor ich die
nächste Rednerin aufgehoben hat
unterbreche ich die Aussprache und kommt
zurück zu Tagesordnungspunkt 32a-32d
die Zeit für die namentliche Abstimmung
die dritten namentliche Abstimmung ist
vorbei deshalb frage ich ist noch ein
Mitglied des Hauses anwesend dass seine
Stimme nicht abgegeben hat oder noch
nicht abgegeben wird
das ist erkennbar nicht der Fall dann
schließe ich die Abstimmung und bitte
die Schriftführung und Schriftführer mit
der Ausbildung zu beginnen das Ergebnis
der namentlichen Abstimmung wird Ihnen
wie immer später bekannt gegeben
da kommen wir zurück zur 33 und ihr Teil
als nächster Rednerin der Kollegin
Yvonne Rey SPD-Fraktion
und der Bundestag debattiert über die
Rolle der Wissenschaft in der
Bundesregierung bei neuen Energien einen
Antrag der COC suchen liebe Kolleginnen
das wichtigste direkt am Anfang die
Ampelkoalition schätzt den Rat der
Wissenschaft die Ampelkoalition lässt
sich sowohl bei kurz als auch bei
Mittel- und langfristigen
Herausforderungen von der Wissenschaft
beraten und die Ampelkoalition bezieht
die Wissenschaft in die politische
Entscheidungsfindung ein dafür brauchen
wir nicht erst einen Antrag der
Unionsfraktion und weil ich erwartet
hätte dass die Frage kommt warum hören
sie dann nicht auf die Wissenschaft das
tun wir als eine seiner ersten
Amtshandlungen hat Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz den corona-expert in den Rat
eingesetzt dieser berät die
Bundesregierung seit fast einem Jahr bei
der Bewältigung der corona-pandemie auf
Basis aktueller Forschungserkenntnisse
haben die ExpertInnen bis jetzt zwölf
Stellungnahmen veröffentlicht diese
Empfehlungen haben wir genutzt und
werden wir auch weiterhin nutzen um
unser Gesundheitssystem auch über die
Pandemie hinaus zu Verb dank der
Wissenschaft überwinden wir die
corona-pandemie und dank der
Wissenschaft und wir besser auf kommende
Pandemien vorbereitet in diesem Sommer
hat der Zukunftsrat der Bundesregierung
seine Arbeit aufgenommen nicht nur ist
die Geschäftsstelle bei der ackertech
der Deutschen Akademie der
technikwissenschaften angesiedelt auch
unter den Teilnehmerinnen sind neben
VertreterInnen aus Wirtschaft und
Gesellschaft viele renommierte
wissenschaftler:innen aller
Fachrichtungen es geht um neue
Entwicklungen Erkenntnisse und Trends um
technologische Potenziale und um Fragen
der gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz es geht
darum gemeinsam Antworten auf die Fragen
unserer Zeit zu finden und Lösungen für
die Herausforderungen der Zukunft dank
der Wissenschaft nutzen wir die
Potenziale der Digitalisierung und
weiterer technologischer Innovationen
und dank der Wissenschaft machen wir den
Standort Deutschland innovativer
unabhängiger und nachhaltiger
und wir wissen alle gerade jetzt ist das
wichtiger als je zuvor schließlich
kommen gerade zu einer noch nicht
überstandenen Pandemie eine Inflation
steigende Lebensmittelpreise und die
Angst um die Versorgungssicherheit durch
Strom und Gas hinzu uns ist wichtig dass
diese Herausforderungen nicht zu einer
existenziellen Krise für die Menschen in
unserem Land werden
deshalb gehört zum Abwehrschirm der
Bundesregierung auch eine gaspreisbremse
die die Energiekosten auffangen soll
diese gaspreisbremse greift Empfehlungen
der expert:innenkommission Gas und Wärme
auf die die Bundesregierung genau zu
diesem Zweck für die wissenschaftliche
Erarbeitung von Vorschlägen zur
Ausgestaltung dieser gaspreisbremse
eingerichtet hat auch hier dank der
Wissenschaft unterstützen und entlasten
wir die Menschen in diesem Winter und
auch dank der Wissenschaft stärken wir
den sozialen Zusammenhalt in unserem
Land
und das sind nur drei Beispiele der
vergangenen Monate angesichts der
Exzellenz unserer wissenschaftler:innen
wäre es gerade zu fahrlässig und ehrlich
gesagt auch dumm auch diese Expertise zu
verzichten und ich weiß wovon ich
spreche schließlich komme ich aus Aachen
dem nicht nur mit Abstand schönsten und
europäischen Wahlkreis sondern vor allem
auch der Hochschule und
Wissenschaftsstadt überhaupt
am E.ON Energy Reset Center der RWTH
Aachen zum Beispiel erforschen
wissenschaftler:innen die
Energieversorgung der Zukunft sie
entwickeln nachhaltige Energiequellen
flexible Netze und Speicher und haben
allein dieses Jahr mehrere Studien
veröffentlicht die sich mit der
Abhängigkeit vom russischen Erdgas
befassen und mit der Frage wie wir
dieser Abhängigkeit möglichst schnell
und nachhaltig entkommen können von der
hervorragenden Forschungsarbeit konnte
ich mich bei Gesprächen und vor Ort
besuchen selbst überzeugen
Beispiele wie dieses zeigen wir können
uns darauf verlassen dass die
Wissenschaft schon jetzt an Antworten
arbeitet auf Fragen die wir uns
vielleicht noch gar nicht stellen und
Lösungen entwickelt für
Herausforderungen mit denen wir noch
nicht konfrontiert sind und das sind
sämtlichen Disziplinen Fachrichtungen
und Forschungsfeldern sie sehen
Forschung und Wissenschaft ihre
Erkenntnisse ihre Arbeit und ihre
Ratschläge spielen eine zentrale Rolle
in der Politik der Bundesregierung und
der Ampelkoalition wir wissen um den
unschätzbaren Wert der Wissenschaft wir
vertrauen ihr als unverzichtbare
Partnerin bei der politischen
Entscheidungsfindung die achten ihre
Freiheit und ihre Unabhängigkeit und
stehen fest an ihrer Seite um sie vor
Angriffen und Verleumdungen zu schützen
wir fördern ihre innovativen Ansätze in
die interdisziplinären Kooperationen und
internationale Vernetzung in der
Grundlagenforschung ebenso wie in der
anwendungsorientierten Forschung aber
vor allem wir danken den
wissenschaftler:innen für ihre Neugier
ihre Kritik ihr Durchhaltevermögen ihren
Einsatz und ihren Rat in guten wie auch
in weniger guten Zeiten
und
nachdem ich mich als öcherin und somit
als Rheinländerin geoutet habe und es
nach elf ist möchte ich diese
Gelegenheit noch nutzen allen Jecken in
ein fröhliches Alarm zu wünschen und als
persönliches Angebot an meinen Kollegen
an meinen Düsseldorfer Kollegen jetzt
schonbeck ein leicht leiseres Helau an
alle vielen Dank
ja Alaaf und Helau auch hier im
Deutschen Bundestag übrigens für jedes
konnten sie nicht sehen um 11 Uhr 11 hat
Wolfgang Kubicki ebenfalls darauf
hingewiesen dass jetzt Karneval sei aber
doch bitte nicht hier im Hohen Hause
aber so viel Zeit muss sein als rein in
der habe ich persönlich volles
Verständnis dafür Michael Kaufmann jetzt
von der AFD
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren Abgeordnete
ein Antrag der die Forschung stärkt
speziell im Bereich der
Energieversorgung trifft bei uns immer
auf offener Ohren sie haben Recht Herr
jazzonbeck es fehlt der
Forschungspolitik der Regierung an einer
klaren Strategie aber was in aller Welt
hat sie dabei geritten die fraglos
vorhandenen guten Ansätze dadurch zu
entwerten dass sie zwar einerseits von
einer unabhängigen ergebnisoffenen
Analyse und Ideologie freier
Bestandsanalyse sprechen aber dann die
Debatte doch wieder auf sogenannte
erneuerbare das heißt überwiegend
wetterabhängige Formen der Energie zu
Erzeugung zu verengen
in der vorliegenden Form hätte dieser
Antrag beinahe auch von den Grünen
kommen können
genau so schlimm wo bleibt die
ergebnisoffene und Ideologie freie
Prüfungen Förderung von neuen
verbesserten Filtersystemen für Kohle
und Gaskraftwerke
wo bleibt wo bleibt die Entwicklung von
co2-speichertechnik im Zusammenhang mit
konventionellen Kraftwerken und nicht
zuletzt wo bleibt die gerne
Energieforschung die mit den neuen
Reaktor Technologien der Generationen 4
und 5 einen substanziellen Beitrag
sowohl zur Versorgungssicherheit als
auch zum Erreichen der Klimaziele
leisten könnte
immerhin
immerhin haben sie wenigstens die
Kernfusion als eine der Form der
Kernkraft in ihre Darstellung mit
einbezogen auch wenn gerade diese
Technologie in einer noch relativ ferne
Zukunft weilst wenn Sie nun in ihrem
Antrag die Möglichkeit der Nutzung von
Sonnenenergie in Ländern hoher
Sonneneinstrahlung ins Spiel bringen
unterschlagen Sie dass Deutschland sich
damit einmal mehr in eine Abhängigkeit
von Ländern begeben würde die schon
morgen keine zuverlässigen Partner mehr
sein könnten ganz abgesehen davon müssen
die dort erzeugten Energieträger ja
irgendwie hierher kommen der damit
verbundene enorme Schadstoffausstoß der
Tankschiff gekannten für die mehr von
der grünen Energie dann vollends
absurdum
die deutsche
die deutsche Energiepolitik muss endlich
die richtigen Prioritäten setzen das
bedeutet vor allem zweierlei erstens wir
brauchen Energieträger deren Ertrag wir
kontrollieren können und die eine
stabile Grundversorgung gewährleisten
dass es bei Sonne und Wind nicht der
Fall zweitens wir müssen uns von
Autokraten und potenziell unsicheren
Partnern weitgehend unabhängig machen
Energieversorgung ist das Rückgrat der
deutschen Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft
deshalb braucht es eine ideologiefreie
und ergebnisoffene Prüfung aller
Optionen und nicht nur solcher die
gerade dem Links-
und natürlich haben sie recht dass es
der Forschungspolitik der Regierung
alleiner clantrage gefehlt und das hier
dringend Abhilfe nötig ist aufgrund der
erkennbaren ideologischen Verengung
Ihres Antrags sehen wir diesen trotzdem
mit großer Skepsis und und empfehlen
Ihnen diesen zu überarbeiten und
wirklich Technologie offen zu gestalten
Deutschland kann sich keine Scheuklappen
und Denkverbote mehr leisten
im Ausschuss zur Bildung und Forschung
wurde der Nobelpreisträger Steven two
ehrend erwähnt nicht zuletzt auch von
ihnen
hat auf der Jahrestagung der
Helmholtz-Gesellschaft im September den
Hauptvortrag gehalten und dabei der
bundes-technik ins Stammbuch geschrieben
ich zitiere
überlegen Sie sich sehr genau ob sie die
Industrien töten wollen die Deutschland
seinen Reichtum bescheren Zitat Ende
genau diese Warnung haben sie mit ihrem
einseitigen Antrag in den Wind
geschlagen danke
vielen Dank Herr Kollege in der Brecher
neu die Aussprache und kommen wir zurück
zu den Tagesordnungspunkten 32A bis
32d
ich konnte zunächst zu TOP 32b und Liebe
in das Ergebnis der namentlichen
Abstimmung in der zweiten Beratung über
den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der
cdu/csu Entwurf eines 19 Gesetzes zur
Änderung des Atomgesetzes 19 ist Tom
Änderungsgesetz Drucksachen 20
34 88 und 20 43 57 bekannt abgegebene
Stimmkarten 655 mit ja haben gestimmt
242 mit Nein haben gestimmt
413 Enthaltungen keine der
Gesetzentwürfe sind zweiter Beratung
damit abgelehnt damit entfällt nach der
Geschäftsführung des Deutschen
Bundestages die dritte Beratung wir
kommen zu TOP 32c das Ergebnis der
namentlichen Abstimmung über die
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Umwelt- und Verbraucherschutz
zum Antrag der Abgeordneten Dr Rainer
Kraft Carsten Hilse mag Bernhard weitere
Abgeordneten und der Fraktion der AFD
Horizont erweitern keine Energie für
umweltfreundliche sichere und
kostengünstige lieferversorgung
Drucksachen 2032 und 20 763
abgegebene Stimmkarten 654 mit ja haben
gestimmt 581 mit Nein haben bestimmt 73
Enthaltungen keine damit ist die
Beschlussempfehlung angenommen wir
kommen zurück ja das waren also die
Ergebnisse der Abstimmung zur Frage
Atomenergie die cdu/csu hatte ja in
ihrem Gesetzentwurf gefordert dass die
Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland bis zum
31.12 24 weiterlaufen sollten
242 Jahre stimmen das sind mehr als die
cdu/csu-fraktion hat aber hat halt nicht
ausgereicht und der Antrag der AFD wurde
ebenfalls abgelehnt interessant noch aus
meiner Sicht das die anwesenden
Abgeordneten von Abstimmung zur
Abstimmung
immer weniger wurden das ist eigentlich
auch keine so schöne Entwicklung beim
Antrag der Ampel der dann angenommen
wurde eben bei dem Gesetzentwurf muss
ich sagen der Ampel waren es immerhin
noch 661 Abgeordnete und dieser Antrags
angenommen worden die Atomkraft in
Deutschland wird verlängert bis zum 15
April und danach ist Schluss es wird
keine neuen bremsstäbe mehr geben das
ist das was der Bundestag hier heute
abgestimmt hat jetzt geht's weiter in
der Debatte Rolle der Wissenschaft in
der Bundesregierung bei neuen Energien
und Anna Christmann für die
Bündnisgrünen hat das Wort
Windkraft Solarenergie all die
Entwicklungen die ja schon da sind dann
ist es natürlich auch wichtig dass wir
diese Technologien auch tatsächlich
einsetzen und die Energiewende in der
Praxis tun und nicht nur über das
sprechen was vielleicht irgendwann mal
passieren könnte beides ist wichtig und
da sehe ich eben einen gewissen
Widerspruch zum Antrag wenn man
einerseits einfordert noch viel mehr
Innovationsförderung zu tun was ich
richtig finde grundsätzlich auf der
anderen Seite wir aber in der Lage jetzt
sind weil all diese Energie Innovationen
in den letzten Jahren eben nicht
eingesetzt worden sind und ich will das
noch mal sagen bei der Windkraft haben
wir eine regelrechte altmaierdelle zu
verzeichnen wenn man noch mal vergleicht
2017 wurden noch
1792 Windkraftanlagen auf dem Land
gebaut 2021 nur noch
484 also nur noch ein Drittel davon die
Genehmigungen sind runtergegangen um 40
Prozent 2020 im Vergleich zu 2015 die
überhaupt nur genehmigt worden sind also
hier haben wir eine Innovation letztlich
ist Windkraft auch eine Technologie die
über die letzten Jahre immer verbessert
worden ist die wir zur Verfügung haben
und dann muss es doch unser erstes Ziel
auch sein diese auch einzusetzen und das
ist das was diese Bundesregierung mit
einem ganz neuen Energie voranbringt im
Gegensatz zu der alten
und das hat im übrigen auch was mit
Innovationen zu tun weil natürlich auch
das Anreize setzt für Energie
Innovationen und diese zu entwickeln
wenn der Staat dann auch derjenige ist
der sie einkauft wie er richtig gesagt
ankerkunde und dann auch einsetzt und
das machen wir natürlich für diese
Bereiche jetzt wir haben mit dem
osterpaket ein Gesetzespaket
verabschiedet im Energiebereich das so
groß war wie lange lange Zeit nicht wir
haben gerade eine offshore-vereinbarung
für Windenergie gemacht am 3.11 Minister
Robert Habeck wir haben einen
wärmepumpengipfel veranstaltet und er
den Hochlauf der Wärmepumpen organisiert
das alles sind ganz konkrete Schritte
bestehende Energie Innovation in die
Praxis zu bringen und das ist das was
die nächsten Jahre ganz konkret für den
Klimaschutz zählt
und dann will ich aber natürlich auch
sagen dass wir das Ziel ausdrücklich
teilen dass wir dabei natürlich nicht
stehen bleiben da geht es darum quasi
das was wir haben möglichst zügig
auszuräumen was versäumt worden ist in
den letzten Jahren und dann geht es aber
und da stimme ich ausdrücklich zu
natürlich darum parallel auch diese
Dinge zu entwickeln die noch kommen
können wo wir noch besser werden können
wo wir vielleicht noch effizientere
Technologien noch klimafreundliche
Energien entwickeln können und deswegen
haben wir uns das ja auch gerade im
Forschungsbereich ganz explizit so
vorgenommen wir haben eine
Zukunftsstrategie verabredet im
Koalitionsvertrag und da ist die erste
Mission genau das was sie ja mit Ihrem
Eintrag vorschlagen also den Vorschlag
hatten wir schon bevor er offenbar
eingefallen ist auch noch in einen
CDU-Antrag aufzunehmen die Mission ist
im Koalitionsvertrag genauso beschrieben
dass Sie moderne Technologien für eine
wettbewerbsfähige und klimaneutrale
Industrie und die Sicherstellung
sauberer Energiegewinn und Versorgung
zum Ziel hat und dort werden wir genau
das tun es geht darum in einer Mission
mit einer klaren Projektsteuerung
ressortübergreifend für erneuerbare
Energien die Forschungs- und
innovationstätigkeiten zu bündeln die
uns eben auch die langfristige
energiesicherung erneuerbar in den
nächsten Jahren sichern werden
und diese Zukunftsstrategie wird ja
jetzt gerade auf den Weg gebracht und
ich möchte auch da vielleicht noch mal
den Vergleich zu dem Handeln der letzten
Bundesregierung bringen denn da hatten
wir ja eine Hightech-Strategie und auch
da standen ja schon viele nette Dinge
drin die sich gut angehört haben auch
was kreisläuft Wirtschaft angeht etc
aber auch dort hat es eben an der
Umsetzung gemangelt und diesen Schritt
wollen wir jetzt mit der
Zukunftsstrategie sehr viel besser
machen dadurch dass wir eben Missionen
einführen genau wie diese das werden wir
ja auch in anderen Bereichen tun wie zum
Beispiel auch bei künstlicher
Intelligenz Digitalisierung die ja auch
eine Auswirkung auf Energietechnologien
haben da gibt es natürlich Bezüge und
damit dass wir aber eine
Projektsteuerung auch für diese
Missionen einsetzen werden
ressortübergreifend gemeinsam mit der
Wissenschaft werden wir auch dafür
sorgen dass diese Innovationen die in
der Mission entwickelt werden dann eben
auch in die Praxis gelangen und uns
wirklich helfen den Energiebereich eben
auch zu deagonisieren in den nächsten
Jahren
darüber hinaus gibt es viele Dinge fürs
Innovationssystem die wichtig sind wir
haben im Juli eine start-up-strategie
vorgelegt in der ein zentraler
Mechanismus in der Finanzierung die ja
auch angesprochen wird im Antrag ist
dass wir einen neuen Fonds aufsetzen den
die Tag and clyded fand climate also mit
einem klaren Ziel dort eben tatsächlich
auch in Start-ups zu investieren die
klimale Technologien entwickeln die neue
Energietechnologien entwickelt das ist
eine Aktivität die wir jetzt sehr
konkret in diesem Bereich voranschreiten
zusammen mit der start-up-strategie mit
der Zukunftsstrategie mit der
Entfesselung der Sprint machen wir genau
das was Sie vorschlagen schon längst wir
bringen das innovationsökosystem auf den
Weg dass uns auch für den Energiebereich
die Innovationen sichern wird die wir
neben dem akuten Ausbau die nächsten
Jahre brauchen werden vielen dank vielen
Dank Frau Kollegin
dass man nächste Rednerin ist die
Kollegin Dr Petra Sitte Fraktion
Petra citys Sprecherin für Forschung
Technologie und herr Präsident meine
Damen und Innovationspolitik
mein Gott jetzt hat sie es die Union hat
endlich die Dringlichkeit einer
nachhaltigen modernen Energieversorgung
erkannt was sie vorschlagen erinnert
zugleich an eine ziemlich alte
unionsförderung das ich zitiere die
Bundesregierung nicht allein nicht auf
ein
kriegskrisenmanagement allein im
aktuellen Versorgungsengpass sich
beschränken dürfen an sie von wann die
Forderung ist von 1973 jo mitten in der
damaligen Ölkrise haben sie das
beantragt dann floss doch noch ziemlich
viel Öl durch die Pipelines später
forderten sie ist die Tiere wieder die
Bundesregierung muss ein in sich
schlüssiges und nachhaltiges
Energiekonzept vorlegen dass die
Behandlung aller noch offenen
Problemfelder beinhaltet auch eine
vernünftige forder diesmal von 1999 aber
in 32
Jahren nachts 1973 hat die Union nichts
vorgelegt was man wirklich als
belastbares Konzept hätte bezeichnen
können
stattdessen
stattdessen haben sie gegen das
erneuerbare Energien Gesetz gezedert
ohne Ende sie haben über windmonster im
Nebel geplabert sie haben wahrlich eher
eine vernebelte Sichtachse auf
erneuerbare Energien entwickelt meine
Damen und Herren
später später später machen wir alles im
Ausschuss meine Damen und Herren wir
hatten in Deutschland Mal weltweit eine
führende Solarbranche nicht nur die Wind
den Windbereich Sachsen-Anhalt
beispielsweise mein Bundesland aus dem
ich komme boomte in sola Valley diese
Branche hat Schwarz-Gelb praktisch über
Nacht die Förderung gekippt seitdem
werden in Deutschland vor allem
chinesische Solarpanels verbaut wenn wir
nachhaltig die Energieversorgung sichern
wollen dann müssen wir eben auch
Solarbranche und Forschung dazu in
Deutschland stärken
und das gilt das gilt natürlich erst
recht für die Zeit nach der
Versorgungskrise der Umstieg auf
erneuerbare Energien ist unverzichtbar
meine Damen und Herren bei den
unionsförderungen nach Konzepten und
Analysen beschleicht mich bisweilen das
Gefühl sie wollen eigentlich nichts
wirklich im Hier und Heute tun
schließlich haben wir doch im Umstieg
und Frau Christmann und die Kollegin von
der SPD hat schon darauf hingewiesen
haben wir doch für den Umstieg auf einer
nachhaltige Energieversorgung nicht
zuerst das Problem fehlender
Erkenntnisse nee nee das haben wir nicht
vielmehr werden die bereits gewonnenen
Erkenntnisse schlicht nicht umgesetzt
ich erinnere mal daran dass der Club auf
Rom unter dem Titel Grenzen des
Wachstums von
1972 bereits auf diesen Umstand
hingewiesen hat
1972 forderte diese zum ersten Mal eine
radikale Energiewende die Wissenschaft
hat sich seitdem jahrzehntelang mit
ihrem Wissen an Bundesregierung und
Bundesregierung relevant aber es
passierte entschieden zu wenig das ist
das Problem und das muss ich ändern
dann machen weitere Forschungen
tatsächlich Sinn so wie es Frau
Christmann angedeutet hat zu
Speichertechnologien beispielsweise zu
Energieeffizienz oder eben auch zu
intelligenten Netzen beispielsweise
zugleich aber muss eben auch aufhören
Stadtwerke und Energiegenossenschaften
beispielsweise Steine in den Weg zu
legen wenn Sie moderne wenn sie
erneuerbare Energieformen einsetzen
wollen wenn Sie moderne Technologien
einsetzen wollen auch wenn dabei die
großen Energiekonzerne mit den
zähnenknirschen es geht auch um in
dezentrale Aufstellung des gesamten
Energiesystems ich schließe meine Rede
mit den Worten des
UN-Generalsekretärs Antonio guterisch
Selbstverpflichtungen zu null Emissionen
sind Null Wert ohne Pläne und taten um
sie umzusetzen also die Energiewende ist
heute dringender denn je und dafür muss
die öffentliche Hand kraftvoll
investieren zeitenwände ist eben auch
Energiewende
sagt Petra Sitte für die Linksfraktion
der nächste Redner kommt von der FDP
Stefan Seite er ist Sprecher für
Forschung Technologie und Innovation
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir reden heute über das Thema neue
Energien wir reden über das Thema
Wissenschaft und ich habe den Antrag der
CDU und CSU mit Interesse gelesen weil
ich sehr wichtig finde dass wir gerade
jetzt in der Phase wo unser
hauptaugenmerken wenn sie auf die Liste
der Debatten in diesem Haus schauen auf
kurzfristige Bewältigung der Krise ist
finde ich es wichtig dass wir auch uns
über die langfristige Entwicklung
Gedanken machen dass wir darüber reden
wie sie der Weg letztendlich in die
nächsten Jahren aus und deswegen habe
ich eigentlich auch das schön gefunden
dass ich zu diesem Antrag reden darf
aber dann habe ich ein bisschen beim
Lesen den anfangs verloren und ich werde
Ihnen auch versuchen zu erläutern warum
es geht um ein sehr wichtiges Thema es
geht um Vorausschau es geht letztendlich
um Strategie mein erster Kritikpunkt da
schließe ich mich meinen Vorrednerinnen
weitgehend an ist das Thema diese
Regierung hört auf die Wissenschaft ja
das machen wir nämlich vom ersten Tag an
diese Regierung hat diese spricht über
die Zukunftsstrategie der Entwurf liegt
vor Frau Christmann hat schon darauf
hingewiesen dort ist genau eine Mission
drin die sich mit diesem Thema neue
Energien beschäftigt auch da kann man
sagen wer hat es erfunden da waren wir
jetzt etwas früher dran aber das sind
zeitliche Unterschiede okay die kann man
schwer bewerten das sind vielleicht
nicht so wichtig aber man sollte darauf
hinweisen dass eben jetzt nichts Neues
kommt ich werde nachher noch darauf
eingehen was mich aber mehr an diesem
Antrag irritiert hat ist
ich nenne es mal die Methodik
und da bin ich vielleicht auch nicht
immer zwingend mit allem ganz einig was
die Vorrednerinnen gesagt haben aber es
geht ja um das Thema Technologie und
technologieoffenheit
und wenn ich dann durch diesen Antrag
durchgehe dann beschleicht mich so ein
bisschen das Gefühl also so richtig
soziale Marktwirtschaft ist da
eigentlich nicht immer drin und ich
möchte Ihnen erläutern warum
das Thema Ordnungspolitik wird ja
normalerweise von der Union sehr hoch
gehalten aber wenn wir uns diesen Antrag
anschauen dann stellen wir fest dass zum
Beispiel eine Forderung enthalten ist
die sagt es sollen technologische Ziele
aufgestellt werden und das sind fünf
zehn fünfzehn Jahresschritten
da könnte man jetzt natürlich wenn man
es etwas salopp ausdrücken wollte sagen
okay gut bei Ordnungspolitik herzlich
willkommen beim 5-Jahres-Plan das möchte
ich der CDU an der Stelle gar nicht
unterstellen und da können wir auch im
Ausschuss gerne darüber reden aber ich
möchte an der Stelle noch mal
eindrücklich darauf hinweisen es geht um
technologieoffenheit wir wollen ja nicht
oder wir können jetzt noch nicht wissen
welche Technologie wird in 15 Jahren die
richtige sein wir können Sie auch nicht
vorher bestimmen sondern wir müssen
letztendlich die Rahmenbedingungen
schaffen und es ist ja auch Ziel der
Regierungspolitik insbesondere auch im
Bundesforschungsministerium dass wir
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen das
technologieoffenheit vorhanden ist
sprich wir schaffen die
Rahmenbedingungen und dann sollten wir
es denjenigen überlassen die die Sache
am besten beherrschen das sind unsere
ForscherInnen das sind unsere Menschen
die in den Laboren arbeiten das sind die
Unternehmen ohne sind letztendlich auch
die Kunden die über Technologien mit
vermeiden sprich das Staat soll
letztendlich die Funktion haben
Rahmenbedingungen zu setzen und wenn ich
dann in ihrem Antrag weitergehe dann
finde ich plötzlich das Wort ankerkunde
und Anker Kunde ist ein interessantes
Konzept das macht man zum Beispiel bei
Einkaufszentren wenn es darum geht einen
großen Flex Store mit reinzukriegen ich
hoffe ich habe es richtig gesagt
Reinhard dass man letztendlich an
Attraktion ausübt aber bei einer Frage
welche Technologie wir letztendlich
auswählen wollen müssen wir uns die
Frage stellen wann kommt dieser
ankokunde tatsächlich zum Tragen zu
Beginn des Lebenszyklus einer
Technologie eines Produkts oder
irgendwann und welche Aufgabe wird diese
angekunde machen wird er uns einen
sogenannten log-in-effekt bescheren dass
wir uns in eine Technologie
festschreiben die vielleicht gar nicht
die tolle Energie tolle Technologie ist
sondern vielleicht verhindert dass wir
eine bessere Lösung finden also auch
darüber sollten wir vielleicht im
weiteren diskutieren es geht also um die
Frage Wettbewerb um bei den Technologien
nicht um Abnahmegarantien und bitte
nicht um das Thema picking the winners
dort gibt es genug historische Beispiele
in diesem Land und dann wird das Thema
Wagniskapital aufgegriffen ja der Staat
hat bei dem Thema Wagniskapital eine
Möglichkeit aber sollten wir uns doch
nicht auch überlegen in der
Verantwortung über Steuergelder wer
entscheidet letztendlich über eine
effiziente Verwendung von Mitteln die
wir in unserer Volkswirtschaft haben und
auch da es stellt sich mir die Frage wie
viel Staat fordert dieser Antrag das
wird mir an dieser Stelle letztendlich
nicht deutlich also wenn ich es etwas
zusammenfassen möchte könnte ich sagen
und bitte liebe Kollegen von der CDU
selbst mir nah es ist jetzt einfach ein
bisschen auch dem vielleicht dem Tag
gewidmet 11.11 der in drei Antrag
enthält vieles was ich denke gut ist
oder vieles was vielleicht insbesondere
für die CDU neu ist
aber das Gute ist nicht zwingend immer
neu und ist neue ist nicht zwingend gut
und deswegen lassen sie mich zum
Abschluss sagen wir brauchen in der
Phase des neuen systemwettbewerbs
technologisches Souveränität wir
brauchen Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
Klimawandel dafür brauchen wir
Technologien und Innovationen aber nicht
vorherbestimmt dass es die einzige
Technologie ist sondern der Weg ist die
ökosoziale Marktwirtschaft der
Wettbewerb der Ideen die Schaffung
Innovationen und das denke ich sollte
unsere gemeinsames Ziel sein vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Seite
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Thomas
Heilmann cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
Frau Ministerin guten Morgen und das
sage ich im doppelten Wort sind denn
dass wir hier eigentlich versuchen ist
ein Weckruf ein Weckruf weil die
Wissenschaftsszene eindeutig unzufrieden
ist und die Energiebranche
ist es eindeutig auch und die bisherigen
reden der Koalition waren auch weniger
reden als Ausreden wenn ich ehrlich bin
liebe Frau Christmann sie haben die
Leistungen des Wirtschaftsministeriums
dargestellt und ich muss ja zugeben die
haben wenigstens ihre Hausaufgaben
gemacht nicht immer mit der Bestnote
aber sie haben welche gemacht denn hier
gibt es keine
und der Seite sie haben lange über die
Anker kundenphilosophiert was stelle
fest dass da offensichtlich auch ein
Unterschied innerhalb ihrer Koalition
gibt den Frau Christmann hat sich ganz
anders geäußert dass sie ich versuchen
die beiden wesentlichen Aspekte die
kurzfristigen und die langfristigen noch
mal auseinander zu nehmen und zu sagen
wo eigentlich das Problem liegt
sie können nichts diese Koalition kann
nichts für diese akute Energiekrise
niemand bezweifelt dass man darauf nicht
vorbereitet war und schon gar nicht war
dass die ist daran die Ampelkoalition zu
sehen aber so war es bei der
corona-krise ja auch
und ich habe gar nicht verstanden dass
sie jetzt den klimaex den
corona-expertenrat zitiert haben weil
genau etwas ähnliches fordern wir ja
gerade für die Frage wie gehen wir denn
jetzt kurzfristig damit um der der von
der alten Koalition eingesetzte
Expertenrat für Klimafragen sagt in dem
Titel seines letzten Gutachtens dass das
ist klar nicht ausreichen wird
was was wir bisher geschafft haben ich
bin Mitglied des Beirates der
Bundesnetzagentur das sind ja auch
fdp-kollegen drin
wir stehen vor ganz vielen ungelösten
Fragen die sich so kurzfristig jetzt
ergeben haben weil wir eben einen von
Putin angezettelten energiekrieg haben
und werden Sie sich doch alle daran
erinnern dass wir in der Schlussphase
der Regierungszeit Merkel jede Woche
Experten gehört haben zum Thema was
machen wir denn jetzt eigentlich ist
einfach von dieser Regierung in dieser
Frage gar nicht zu hören es gibt sehr
schöne Bekenntnisse zu Wissenschaft von
ihnen die würde ich auch alle
unterschreiben
auch die FDP tut das wunderbar ich habe
mir das in der Vorbereitung
aufgeschrieben auf ihrer Webseite steht
wir bekennen uns zum wichtigen Beitrag
der Wissenschaft im demokratischen
Beratungsprozessen um faktenbasierte
Entscheidungen zu ermöglichen in unserer
Lernenden Demokratie sind
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse an
unverzichtbare Grundlage ja genau
richtig und warum tun sie das in der
Energiekrise
also es gibt dazu überhaupt gar keine
keinen Dialog obwohl die Frage
kurzfristig gibt es offene Fragen und es
gibt mittelfristig oft die Gefahren wir
wissen doch alle dass das Konzept des
Umbaus zu erneuerbaren Energie waren
dass die Energie Lücken die sich ergeben
mit Gaskraftwerken kurzfristig gelöst
werden sollen das Konzept ist jetzt bei
der Frage wir kriegen kein günstiges Gas
oder kein günstiges Pipeline Gas über
Russland
vorsichtig formuliert angegriffen und da
müssen wir uns doch jetzt mal über die
Frage unterhalten wie funktioniert denn
diese Transformation und alle Gremien
die es dazu gibt sagen wir haben dazu
wenig zu antworten es gibt aber
keinerlei
systematische Aufarbeitung wie kommen
wir denn zu diesen Ergebnissen aufs
Forschung und wissenschaftspolitischer
Hinsicht das hat nichts mit der Frage zu
tun was das bmwk macht sondern das ist
natürlich eindeutig Aufgabe des
Ministeriums für Forschung und
Wissenschaft der wird Klimarat sagt 50%
der techn Termin die wir 2050 brauchen
sind noch nicht fertig entwickelt was
für eine Agenda für einen
Wissenschaftsministerium wir hören dazu
nichts wenn Sie mir nicht glauben ich
habe
dann glauben sie vielleicht Ulrike Gothe
von den Grünen die angesichts dieser
Unklarheiten der Zukunft für Forschung
und Forschungsförderung gerade
öffentlich gesagt hat letzte Woche es
sei ein affrondes
gegenüber dem Wissenschaftsrat ich meine
klarer können doch die die Äußerungen
aus der Betroffenen Energiebranche aus
der in der Betroffenen Energieforschung
aus von einer grünen
Wissenschaftsministerin aus dem Land
Berlin nicht sein und in Vorbereitungen
dieser Rede habe ich gesagt naja
vielleicht habe ich auch irgendwas
verpasst also man kriegt ja manchmal
nicht mit und was macht man dann man
googelt und Frau stark Watzinger ich
habe ihren Namen gegoogelt in
Kombination mit energietransformation
ich habe vier Einträge gefunden über ein
ganzes Jahr und dann habe ich
Energieforschung eingegeben war auch
nicht besser und wenn sie nicht in
Karlsruhe gewesen wären offensichtlich
Ende
Oktober die ja zur Energieforschung
tätig sind das zuständige Kit dann
werden die Einträge noch viel weniger
gewesen
im Verwaltungsrecht gibt es die gibt es
die Möglichkeit der sogenannten
Untätigkeitsklage das gibt es eine
Politikbetrieb leider nicht aber das was
wir mit unserem Antrag sagen wollen ist
nutzen Sie in der aktuellen Energiekrise
die Wissenschaft viel stärker ist gibt
viele unklare fragen wir werfen nicht
vor dass die Fragen unklar sind wir
werfen ihn aber vor dass sie die
Wissenschaft nicht anständig einbinden
deswegen bitte fangen sie an zu handeln
die Energie und Klimakrise ist zu
wichtig als dass wir die Wissenschaft
nicht aktiv in unserem Politikbetrieb
einbinden vielen Dank
Thomas Heimann war das für die
cdu/csu der nächste Redner hier in der
Debatte über die Rolle der Wissenschaft
in der Bundesregierung bei neuen
Energien ist Holger Becker von der SPD
ist Mitglied im Ausschuss für Bildung
Forschung und technologie-
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen sie kennen
sicherlich die folgende Situation sie
sind im Urlaub und morgens am Pool wenn
die Anlage öffnet Rennen ein paar
Touristen wie von der Tarantel gestochen
zu den Liegen werfen dort ein Handtuch
drauf
warum ich Ihnen das erzähle
Beitrag der Wissenschaft zur Lösung der
aktuellen Energiekrise so lautet der
Antrag der hier ursprünglich besprochen
werden sollte und das war ihr Handtuch
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union dass sie erst mal auf die Liege
geworfen haben nach dem Motto erstmal
Debatte anmelden zeitlos sichern uns
fällt dann sicherlich was ein nun
diskutieren nun diskutieren wir hier
einen Antrag mit einem ganz anderen
Zungenschlag zunächst würde ich ihnen
tatsächlich auch zugestehen dass der
Titel ihres Antrages zum Teil ganz in
meinem Sinne als Wissenschaftler ist
nämlich die Rolle von Wissenschaft in
der Regierung zu stärken und hier und da
wie auch Kollege Seiter schon angemerkt
hat sind Elemente dabei die sind auch
nicht schlecht wir sind aber eben auch
nicht neu ein paar Beispiele Startups
und KMU zu fördern wie in Punkt 12
genannt ist eigentlich immer ein
ratsames vorgehen denn KMU sind
Start-ups sind der Maschinenraum der
deutschen Wirtschaft es freut mich dass
sie das erkannt haben nachdem ihr
letzter Wirtschaftsminister ja eher eine
holpriges Verhältnis in diese Richtung
hatte
ich denke allerdings da stoßen wir mit
der bereits vorliegenden
start-up-strategie natürlich schon ganz
bedeutende Entwicklungen an es gibt
bereits heute im Bereich Innovationen in
der Energiewende über 100 junge
Unternehmen in diesem Land die uns an
den verschiedensten Stellen mit den
verschiedensten Technologien ganz
entscheidend voranbringen und nicht
umsonst waren wir als SPD-Fraktion im
Rahmen unserer Klausur in Dresden zum
Beispiel beim Unternehmen zu Gast das
Anlagen zur Wasserstoff Elektrolyse
herstellt
mit der Sprint haben wir zudem bereits
heute ein Instrument das genau jene
schnelle Umsetzung dieses from Lab to
Fab wie sie sehr schön in Punkt 3
formuliert haben bereits als
Arbeitsauftrag hat auch ihr Punkt 7
indem sie das sogenannte pre-commercial
procurement also den Start als
ankerkunden vorschlagen ist schon längst
Teil des Regierungshandelns auch dem ist
in der start-up-strategie dass ich ein
eigenes Kapitel gewidmet
nun nun gut was was steht denn sonst
noch so da sie fordern die
Bundesregierung auf eine
technologieagenda neue Energien zu
erstellen das klingt ganz spannend aber
was ist es denn das stellen wir nämlich
nicht da weiter geht der Satz in Punkt 1
nämlich nicht
und sie nehmen auch nur ein einziges Mal
bei Punkt 8 nämlich konkret Bezug auf
eine sogenannte auf dieser Agenda wenn
es um Vergabe geht und auch da ist es so
dass natürlich Start-ups und KMU's bei
Forschungsvorhaben bereits jetzt schon
besonders zum zugekommen das ist geübte
Praxis bei Förderrichtlinien sie fordern
zudem ein ich zitiere strategischen
Prozess mit einer Ideologie freien
evidenzbasierten Bestandsanalyse
aufzusetzen
das klingt auch erstmal gut aber wie so
oft schlägt der Teufel im Detail wenn
die Union nämlich von Ideologie frei
spricht ist zu befürchten dass sie das
genaue Gegenteil meint sie stellen sich
hin und fordern Ideologie Freiheit bei
Energiefragen aber wie sieht es bei
ihnen selbst aus in meinem Land in
Thüringen bekämpft die Union natürlich
völlig Ideologie frei mit Windkraft mit
Zähnen und Klauen und das gestrige
Urteil des Bundesgerichtshof hat hier
glücklicherweise positiv eingegriffen
auch
auf die AFD dass wenn man das die AFD
das multidimensional tote Pferd der
sogenannten friedlichen Nutzung der
Kernenergie reiten möchte wundert mich
nicht die vorangegangene Abstimmung in
diesem Haus hat hier einen
glücklicherweise eine deutliche Stimme
gesprochen und fragen Sie mal die Leute
bei Helmholtz die er wirklich
Energieforschung machen da werden sie
niemand finden der diesem Thema auch nur
ein Mühe Zukunftspotenzial zuordnet
was haben wir denn sonst noch unter
Punkt 6 sprechen sie von Forschung
Entwicklung im Bereich der
Speichertechnologien und auch davon sich
neue Ansätze im Bereich Kernfusion
genauer anzuschauen keine schlechte Idee
genauso diesen Punkten liegen dem Büro
für Technikfolgenabschätzung des
Deutschen Bundestags nämlich bereits
untersuchungsanträge vor das
Interessante dabei diese Anträge kamen
nicht auf Initiative der Union sondern
die kann auch von unserer Seite auf der
auf der Initiative der SPD wir die
Koalition ist es Sie diese
technologischen Entwicklungen
vollständig und Ideologie frei im Blick
hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union sie reden davon ein Potenzial zu
nutzen dass sie selbst jahrelang
wirklich konsequent ignoriert haben
geben vor Ideen und Konzepte für eine
energieagenta in der Schubladen zu haben
werden sie es waren die über Jahre aktiv
die Energiewende in diesem Land
sabotierten ausgebremst haben es war ihr
Umweltminister und späterer
Wirtschaftsminister der sich 2012 wie
auch Kollegen sind schon bemerkt hat
öffentlich über den Zusammenbruch der
Photovoltaikindustrie gefreut hat es ist
schön zu sehen dass sie von der Union
Forschung Energiebereich als Thema für
sich entdeckt haben es ist noch schöner
allerdings dass wir in unserer Koalition
eben diesen Weg bereits ein gutes Stück
weit zurückgelegt haben und dass wir
dabei auf dem Weg sind eine innovative
technologisch vielfältige nachhaltige
sichere und ökonomisch sinnvolle
Energieversorgung anzugehen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Becker
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin Nicole
höchst auf die Fraktion
herr Präsident Werte Kollegen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren der
vorliegende Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion
ist
eine bemerkenswerte Umkehr vom
energiewendenden Holzweg vielleicht
können die anderen Fraktionen von ihnen
etwas lernen
nicht Corona nicht Putin sind schuld an
der deutschen Energiekrise es ist die
deutsche Energiepolitik der letzten
Jahrzehnte denn mit ihrer aller
Beteiligung wurde 2000 die völlig
verfehlte Energiewende mit dem EEG
beschlossen unter Frau Bundeskanzlerin
Angela Merkel 2011 die völlig
irrationale Entscheidung aus der
Zukunftstechnologie Kernenergie
auszusteigen wegen eines
jatzunamis in Fukushima unter ihrer
Verantwortung wurde der Ausstieg aus der
Kohleverstromung 2020 und die
gasabhängigkeit von Russland
verabschiedet Sie meine Damen und Herren
hier im Deutschen Bundestag stellten
maßgeblich alle Weichen für den
Rückschritt Deutschlands zum
industriellen Entwicklungsland
[Applaus]
sie waren liebe Kollegen von der CDU
CSU-Fraktion maßgeblich
mitverantwortlich für die Einrichtung
einer konsens-politik und einer
konsenswissenschaft den magischen 97
Prozent unter der knote der
ideologischen Alternativlosigkeit die
Ampel hat indes die
energiewendepolitik in Zeiten der Krise
intensiviert die Energiepreise
explodieren der Zusammenbruch der
Energieversorgung droht in diesem Winter
die BASF in Ludwigshafen ist mit
39.000 Arbeitsplätzen auf dem Sprung
nach China die traditionellen
Edelsteinschleifer in Idar-Oberstein
stehen vor dem Aus nur um einige Male zu
nennen ihre Energiepolitik besteht in
Verteuerung und Verknappung von Energie
in Zeiten der Krise das muss man so hart
gesagt werden meine Damen und Herren
sie lösen mit ihren Missionen das
weltklimaproblem nicht von Deutschland
aus nicht einmal wenn sie dafür die
deutsche Wirtschaft die deutsche
Wissenschaft und die Bevölkerung über
die Klippe springen lassen durch ihre
Politik ist auch der
Wissenschaftsstandort Deutschland direkt
gefährdet bei den von ihnen zu
verantwortenden Energiepreisen kann der
Wissenschaftsbetrieb nicht mehr aufrecht
erhalten werden liest man in der
allianzstellungnahme zu Wissenschaft und
Forschung in der Energiekrise ihre
Politik treibt Deutschland in den Ruinen
während die Wirtschaft und Wissenschaft
wo anders floriert ihr erklärter Feind
der CO2-Fußabdruck wandert einfach nur
woanders hin was für eine Heuchelei ich
bitte Sie
ich bitte Sie dem Antrag von der CDU CSU
diskursiv näher zu treten da ist
vielleicht der richtige Weg dankeschön
vielen
[Applaus]
Laura Kraft Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
Laura Kraft ist ob Frau im Ausschuss für
Bildung Forschung und
Technikfolgenabschätzung für ihre
Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren ja heute wurde bereits
viel über Energiepolitik gesprochen und
ich bin noch froh dass wir über das
Thema Energieforschung jetzt sprechen
denn die Entwicklung in der
Energietechnologie und Energieversorgung
die ist ohne Forschung einfach nicht
denkbar aber da muss ich mal eins vorweg
sagen Sie haben ja eben schon erklärt
auch in ihren Reden wie toll sie
recherchiert haben
ja das kann ja nicht so erfolgreich
gewesen sein denn wenn sie nämlich
einfach Google benutzen dann wären sie
wahrscheinlich auch auf die Seite von
bmwk gestoßen und da müssen wir nämlich
noch mal über Ressort Zuständigkeiten
sprechen denn da unter Energieforschung
de ist die Zuständigkeit bmwk gewesen
nicht BMWF und das schon die Seite ist
schon von 2018 so also dann auch unter
ihre Regierung und wenn sie dann auf der
Seite beim BMBF unterwegs sind dann
haben wir auch einen Bericht zur siebten
energieforsch Programm von 2020 also
auch bei ihnen gewesen also geht es gar
nicht darum was hier einfach nie gemacht
wurde sondern da ist ja auch schon viel
gefördert worden ja auch in ihrer also
auch in der Vorgängerregierung auch
unter ihnen also es ist nicht so als
hätten sie jetzt dieses Thema noch mal
ganz neu aufgebracht und hätten das noch
mal ganz neu irgendwo gefunden sondern
da ist ja auch schon länger auch viel
passiert und dann frage ich mich was ist
denn ihr Motto ist das also so wie ich
den Antrag lese ist das dann einfach
schwach angefangen und dann stark
nachgelassen oder wie
die Ampel wird anders als die Union die
Forschungsausgaben insgesamt auf 3,5%
des BIP bis 2025 erhöhen und das ist
einiges wir stehende Energiewende nicht
im Weg wir fördern Sie ganz gezielt und
auch durch Investitionen und
gleichzeitig verfolgen wir jetzt Ampeln
stark wissenschaftsbasierte Politik und
in der wissenschaftlich Erkenntnis eine
hohe Bedeutung haben und da muss ich
auch noch mal ganz einfach Werbung
machen für das Büro für Technikfolgen
Abschätzung ich weiß gar nicht ob das
auch vielen Parlamentariern so bekannt
ist aber wir arbeiten da ja auch als
Berichterstatterin und Berichterstatter
und wenn Sie einfach mal auf die Seite
schauen da gibt es wirklich sehr viele
Themen sehr viele Projekte die sich auch
eben mit Zukunft
vielversprechender zukunftsgerichteter
Energie Forschung befassen und da auch
ja eine Technikfolgenabschätzung eben
durchführen und das ist einfach enorm
wichtig also wir stehen für
wissenschaftsbasierte für
evidenzbasierte Politik und wir müssen
dann das auch einfach stärken und dann
müssen wir da als Parlamentarier und
parlamentarium mal gucken was wir hier
auch eigentlich im eigenen Haus haben wo
wir auch Kooperationen pflegen und ja
wie wir das in unserer
Entscheidungsfindung natürlich dann auch
noch weiter und stärker mit einfließen
lassen können
und
uns grün ist besonders wichtig wir
wissen wie wichtig Forschung zu Lösung
der Klimakrise ist aber
selbstverständlich auch andere
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit und ja
herzlichen Glückwunsch einfach an die
jungen dass sie jetzt die Wichtigkeit
der Energiewende erkennen wir haben ja
nicht nur wir haben ja in der Regel kein
Erkenntnisproblem wir haben ein
Umsetzungsproblem und die Energiepolitik
wurde in der Vergangenheit also hin zur
nachhaltiger Energiepolitik wurde leider
auch zu oft blockiert auch von ihnen und
das merkt man noch daran dass in ihrem
Antrag es wirklich
systematisch vermeiden das Wort
Energiewende zu verwenden Sie verwenden
sie reden von energietransformation aber
vielleicht klingt ihn einfach
Energiewende zu grün ich weiß nicht was
da los war aber gut ist so ist okay
okay Frau höchst ja also ich bin froh
dass der Antrag nun neue Energien als
Lösung für die aktuelle Krise in der
Zukunft sieht und davon hat man ja von
der Union eigentlich zuvor noch ganz
andere Töne gehört aber Unabhängigkeit
im Energiebereich werden wir in der
Zukunft vor allen Dingen durch ein
neuerbare Energien erreichen die
technologischen Entwicklung der
solarzellenforschung die zeigen uns wie
durch beeindruckende Forschung die
Energieversorgung immer effizienter
gestaltet werden kann aber leider haben
wir den Standort hier in Deutschland in
der Solarindustrie ja vor die Hunde
gehen lassen und das ist ein
Riesenproblem wir stehen vor großen
Herausforderungen heute und auch in der
Zukunft und die Probleme und Krise
unserer Zeit die lassen sich nur lösen
wenn wir Forschung auch auskömmlich
finanzieren und dafür setzen wir uns in
der
Ampelkoalition ein
und die unionvolle die ehrenantrag des
in den entlastungspaketen auch Beiträge
für Investitionen die Forschung und
Bildung von Zukunftstechnologien sein
sollen aber da muss man auch noch mal
sagen das muss man auch Trend
entlastungspakete sind in erster Linie
nicht dafür da Investitionen zu tätigen
sondern entlastungspakete sollen
entlassen und wir entlasten hier auch
ganz gezielt Wissenschaft und Forschung
in der Krise denn wir sehen auch wie die
Forschungseinrichtungen natürlich auch
belastet sind in der jetzigen Situation
und da schaffen wir mit unseren
verziehen
verschiedenen entlastungspaketen auch
Abhilfe dankeschön
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
Laura Kraft war das auf sie folgt eine
weitere
abmaier Waldstein spricht jetzt für die
SPD-Fraktion sie sitzt im Ausschuss für
Bildung Forschung und
Technikfolgenabschätzung
liebe Besucherinnen und Besucher schön
dass Sie da sind liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe service-oppositionen ganz
besonders sie sind gegrüßt ich spiele ja
ernsthaft mit dem Gedanken ihrem Antrag
zuzustimmen ich stimme zum Beispiel zu
ja wir müssen Klimaneutralität bis 2025
erreichen und dafür brauchen wir eine
echte Transformation
mir ist ihr Sinneswandel in diesem
Bereich natürlich nicht entgangen und
ich finde es schön dass Sie liebe Union
das mittlerweile fordern spitzwindige
Zungen hier im Haus haben der heute
schon erwähnt hätte ihre Partei ihr
Minister Altmaier das früher auch schon
gut gefunden dann werden wir heute schon
weiter aber so spitzfindig bin ich heute
gar nicht viel mehr möchte ich ihnen
zustimmen wie ich sagte dem Antrag kann
man ja auch zustimmen wenn wir gemeinsam
ein paar Änderungen vornehmen wenn wir
zum Beispiel ein bisschen sortieren und
das Potpourri zusammengewürfelter und
auch Zusammenhang loser Forderungen
bereinigen also wenn Sie meine Stimme
wollen und das also hatte ich sie ja
auch verstanden
müssten unbedingt ihre Forderungen nach
einer technologieagenda und einer
Mission neue Energien raus das klingt
nämlich eigentlich sehr schön aber das
sind eigentlich nur Überschriften ohne
Inhalte und sowas konnte ich noch nie
leiden in drei ihrer 12 Forderungen
erwähnen Sie kleine und mittlere
Unternehmen und Start-ups um diese dann
zu bevorzugen und es ist sinnvoll
Start-ups und KMU zu fördern gerade in
Ostdeutschland haben wir viele kleine
und mittlere Unternehmen aber zum einen
glaube ich nicht dass das die Rolle der
Wissenschaft in der Bundesregierung
stärkt wie ist ja der Titel ihres
Antrags fordert und zum anderen sollte
man wenn man Wissenschaft fördern und
stärken will nicht die Auswahl der
Kooperationspartner verengen
ihre Forderung zur Zusammenarbeit der
Ressortforschung mit der akademischen
Forschung die finde ich interessant ein
bisschen unklar aber interessant die
ressortforschungseinrichtung der
Bundesministerium und die arbeiten ja
nicht losgelöst von der sonstigen
Wissenschaft sondern die betreiben doch
schon akademische Forschung sie
kooperieren mit wissenschaftler:innen in
Universitäten und publizieren auch in
den üblichen Journals die
Ressortforschung wird auch vom
Wissenschaftsrat regelmäßig evaluiert
mit Blick auf die wissenschaftliche
Qualität und jetzt frage ich mich welche
der ressortforschungseinrichtungen die
zu neuen Energien forscht arbeitet in
ihrer Meinung nach nicht vernünftig mit
der akademischen Forschung zusammen also
ernsthaft ich frag mich welche der
Forschungseinrichtungen sie da auf dem
Kieker haben würde mich interessieren
wir haben heute noch ein paar
Redebeiträge vielleicht gehen sie darauf
ein
aber zwei ihrer 12 Forderungen
unterstützt sich und da wollen sie ja
tatsächlich die Rolle der Wissenschaft
in der Bundesregierung entsprechend des
antragsziels stärken das sind Punkt 2
und Punkt 4 und die gute Nachricht ist
unabhängige ergebnisoffene
wissenschaftliche Analysen zu einer
sicheren bezahlbaren und
klimafreundlichen Energieversorgung
Deutschland so wie sie es hier schreiben
ja das machen wir bereits und zwar im
Förderbereich Energiesystem
energiesystemanalyse des
energieforschungsprogramms des bmwk
außerdem gibt es ein Projekt mit dem
Titel langfrist Szenarien für die
Transformation des Energiesystems
ebenfalls im Auftrag des bmwk und die
Bundesregierung wird 2023 ein neues
Energie-
ihre grundsätzliche Forderung nach der
Förderung von Forschung und Entwicklung
von neuen Energien die ist natürlich
absolut richtig und auch hier eine gute
Nachricht auch das tun wir schon das
siebte Energieforschungsprogramm der
Bundesregierung Innovation für die
Energiewende das hat ein Umfang von 970
Millionen Euro sie fordern konkret unter
anderem Forschung zu
Speichertechnologien und
Leitungssystemen super super die werden
zum Beispiel direkt in meinem Wahlkreis
in Cottbus erforscht das neue Energie
Innovationszentrum der BTU Cottbus
Senftenberg wird vom BMBF gefördert und
soll gezielte Innovationen sowie
industrienahe produktorientierte
Technologieentwicklung und Transfer
vorantreiben auch vom BMBF gefördert
wird das neue DLR-Institut für
elektrifizierte luftfahrtantriebe in
Cottbus das emissionsärmere
flugtriebwerke erforschen wird und dass
Fraunhofer-Institut für Geothermie und
Energieinfrastrukturen ebenfalls bei mir
zu Hause in Cottbus Cottbus entwickelt
sich immer mehr zu einer der dynamischen
energieforschungsstandorte Deutschlands
kommen sie mich sehr sehr gerne besuchen
sie sind sowieso immer ganz besonders
herzlich willkommen und bei Cottbuser
Baumkuchen und fürs Pückler Bier da kann
man sich auch gut entspannen das nimmt
dann ein bisschen den Stress raus den
Sie jetzt vielleicht hier empfinden
zusammengefasst das was logisch und
sinnvoll ist in ihrem Antrag das machen
wir bereits und darum werden Sie
sicherlich Verständnis haben und
einsehen dass ich ihrem Antrag dann am
Ende doch nicht ganz zustimmen kann aber
die Einladung die steht herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
das wird ja eine richtige Sause wenn 739
nur die Union
ich glaube ich glaube das ist ein
Verstoß gegen das die
Diskriminierungsverbot von
Andersgläubigen nächster Redner ist der
Kollege Stefan
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen als einer
der letzten Redner in dieser Debatte
muss ich dann doch mit ein paar Punkten
erstmal ein bisschen aufräumen einige
der Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel
haben gesagt sie hören auf die
Wissenschaft ja das finde ich Ihnen auch
gar nicht in Abrede stellen aber nachdem
man gehört hat sollte man noch tun nach
dem schönen Spruch von Goethe es gibt
nichts Gutes außer man tut es und da
waren in den Ausführungen zum Beispiel
von Frau Christmann ja schon einige
Dinge drin die wollen wir auch gar nicht
in Abrede stellen aber wenn man gerade
und hat sie ihre Rede noch mal anschauen
wollen gegen Ende doch einiges wollen
und einiges planen und einiges überlegen
drin okay alles auf einmal können sie
nicht machen aber der Punkt ist dass
viele der Punkte ja halt in einer Agenda
und genau das ist das was wir fordern in
einen sinnvollen Zusammenhang gesetzt
werden sollen und nicht mit wir wollen
hier wir machen da wir tun dies wir tun
jenes wie es in der gerade in der Rede
meiner Vorrednerin gemacht ist also dem
Ganzen einen Sinn geben Herr Dr Seiter
sie haben an dieser Stelle uns dafür
kritisiert dass wir gesagt haben wir
hätten in 15 der genau das ist aber das
Element einer Agenda dass man sagt was
soll nach welcher Zeit geschehen das ist
natürlich im nicht im Sinne von dass wir
sind sicher dass es dort ist aber es
muss einen Plan ein Zeitplan geht getreu
dem Motto aus Träumen während Planungen
den man ein Datum dahinter setzt und
wenn man halt dieses nicht tut dann
bleiben es Träume Vorstellung und
Wunschlisten also insofern das sind die
Punkte die ich gegenüber meinen
Vorrednern einmal deutlich machen wollte
und der Kollege Heimann hatte schon
erwähnt
der Expertenrat für Klimafragen hat halt
in seiner Kritik das die Ziele für 2030
und die Erreichung derer fraglich sind
ohne Paradigmenwechsel nicht unsere
Politik gemeinsam das was jetzt jetzt
bei ihnen vorgelegt wird und insofern so
sehr sie sich auch gerne an uns
abarbeiten hier geht es dann doch um die
Dinge die sie momentan anlegen und
insofern möchte ich dann doch die zweite
Hälfte meiner Redezeit für die Dinge
verwenden die mir am Herzen liegen in
diesem Zusammenhang und ich beginne an
der Stelle mit den Ausführungen oder mit
einem Zitat von Sound exupery weil es
mir an dieser Debatte bisher nicht
gefällt er hat gesagt was die Zukunft
anbelangt so haben wir nicht die Aufgabe
sie vorherzusehen wie einige der
Kollegen das hier versucht haben sondern
sie zu ermöglichen und genau das ist das
was nicht geschieht es bis gibt keine
Planung es gibt nichts es gibt und das
wurde eben sehr deutlich es wurde
übrigens überwiegend bmwk erwähnt das
heißt eine wirklich sinnhafte
Zusammenarbeit zwischen BMBF bmwk und am
Ende auch der Wirtschaft die das ganze
ausrollen kann ist halt im Sinne eines
Gesamtprozesses nicht und genau das ist
das was wir hier fordern
also nein keine Doppelstruktur sondern
eine Prozesskette die ineinander greift
und auf diese Art und Weise am Ende auch
einen Effekt erzeugt und nicht einfach
nur viel bewegt und wenig erreicht und
wenn wir auf die Frage nach planvollen
oder sinnvollen optimalen Lösungen der
zukünftigen Energiefragen kommen ist mir
in der Diskussion heute auch wieder
eines aufgefallen ich habe noch nicht
mal das Gefühl es geht mehr weniger um
Wissenschaft und die Frage von
ergebnisoffen und kenntnisreich sondern
es geht darum als würde es ja als würden
wir Ersatz energiereligionen gründen
wollen und uns gegenseitig immer fragen
sag mal bist du eigentlich der mit Wind
und ich bin eher für Wasserstoff ich bin
für Fusion bist du für Regeneration was
weiß ich also immer entweder oder bist
du dies oder jenes wir wollen dies wir
wollen jenes
das halte ich für falsch das falsche
daran sind nicht die Technologien das
falsche ist das Wort oder das heißt wir
werden all diese Technologien brauchen
und wir brauchen sie in unterschiedliche
auf in unterschiedlicher Art und Weise
an unterschiedliche Stellen und liebe
Kollegen von der AFD herkaufmann genau
das war der Inhalt im Wesentlichen des
Kollegen der das Nobelpreisträgers zu
der halt deutlich gemacht hat dass wir
hier letzten Endes Lösungen machen
müssen die an die Orte und in die
Kontexte passen wo sie sinnvoll
eingesetzt werden und genau dafür ist
eine Agenda die wir hier vom Ministerium
fordern
[Applaus]
und wenn wir schon beim Aufräumen sind
hier war eben wieder die Situation
Kernfusion und Kernspaltung wurden in
einem Absatz erwähnt da für euch
hoffentlich viele da draußen zuhören
diese beiden Dinge haben so viel
miteinander zu tun wie Gustav von
Gasthof nämlich außerdem Wort Kern
nichts und das eine ist eine Technologie
die in ihrer Sinnhaftigkeit in ihrem
Risiko durchaus durch sinnhaft an dieser
Stelle zu einem Ende kommen wird wir
sind der Meinung dass in der derzeitigen
Situation dieses 2024 sein sollte andere
sehen dieses als nicht sinnvoll an
darüber ist der Diskurs zu führen aber
die Technologie ist eine Technologie von
gestern und die Kernfusion ist davon
völlig bitte zu trennen und die
Kernfusion ist eine Zukunft von morgen
und hier investieren wir hier gibt es
Start-ups hier müssen wir an dieser
süßen keine Fake News als Physiker kann
ich Ihnen sagen tun sie sich das mal
genau anschauen es hat miteinander
nichts zu tun
und die Aussage dass so etwas halt
Zukunftsmusik ist oder dass dieses
entsprechend unter umständlich erreicht
werden kann wir haben im Rahmen unseres
Studiums die Kollegen die Fusion gemacht
haben immer ein bisschen damit geärgert
dass wir gesagt haben ist das nicht
fürchterlich wenn ihr jeden Morgen aus
der Tür tretet und da oben lacht euch
die Sonne an und sagt ätschibätsch ich
kann was was ihr noch nicht könnt
und genau darum wird es gehen wenn wir
am Ende des Tages mittels einer Agenda
dieses Ziel erreichen wollen und so
möchte ich schließen mit den Worten von
Albert Einstein eine wirklich gute Idee
erkennt man daran dass die
Verwirklichung von vornherein nahezu
ausgeschlossen scheint und insofern
sollten wir uns diese Punkte rangehen
das ist Forschung aber BMWF steht am
Anfang dann bmwk und die Wirtschaft am
Ende dann kommen wir auch zum Ziel
herzlichen Dank vielen dank der Kollege
[Applaus]
ist die Kollegin Maria Schröder
FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen kennen sie
ellish Parker oder Maria telkesh beide
waren Erfinderinnen sie haben in Zeiten
von Krisen mit ihren Erfindungen den
Grundstein für technologische
Innovationen gelegt Entschuldigung im
Bereich der Energieversorgung und
Energiesicherheit die afroamerikanische
Erfinderin
ellish Parker konstruierte während des
Ersten Weltkriegs eine regulierbare
Gasheizung die Entwicklung von
Zentralheizungen möglich machte nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg entwickelte die
ungarische amerikanische biophysikerin
Maria telkesh die erste Solaranlage der
Welt diese Erfinderinnen sind uns
Vorbild Wissenschaft und Forschung
werden uns auch aus dieser Krise heraus
innovieren
aber nicht durch planwissenschaft Liebe
Union sowie der Staat nicht der bessere
Unternehmer ist so ist der auch nicht
der bessere Wissenschaftler die Aufgabe
von Politik ist es Rahmenbedingungen zu
setzen in denen ForscherInnen
Wissenschaftler und Erfinderinnen sich
entfalten können und das tut diese
Bundesregierung Liebe Union entweder
haben sie die letzten Wochen unter einem
Stein gelebt oder Sie wollen die
Menschen in die Irre führen wenn sie
behaupten Wissenschaft und Forschung
sein bei den entlastungspaketen leer
ausgegangen das ist falsch Wissenschaft
und Forschung stehen unter dem
abwehrstürmen der Bundesregierung sie
profitieren von den Soforthilfen genauso
wie von der Gas- und strompreisbremse
und für außeruniversitäre
Forschungseinrichtungen gibt es einen
härtefallfonds diese Informationen die
waren am Mittwoch als ihr Antrag dann
endlich vorlag auch hinlänglich bekannt
also hören Sie bitte auf mit diesen
falsch behaupten
wir meine Damen und Herren wir schaffen
die Rahmenbedingungen die
Zukunftsstrategie ist angesprochen
worden nehmen Sie die GWK Beschlüsse aus
der letzten Woche die Dynamisierung des
zukunftsvertragsstudium und Lehre die
Ausweitung der Exzellenz in Strategie
für die universitäre Spitzenforschung
und meine Damen und Herren das zeigen
doch die Beispiele von ls age Parker und
von Maria telkesh das Wissenschaft
Männer und Frauen braucht daher ist das
professorinprogramm 2030 ebenso
richtungsweisend für Wissenschaft und
Forschung in unserem Land
und meine Damen und Herren wir denken an
die Zukunft die WissenschaftlerInnen und
Erfinder von morgen die stecken heute
noch in den Kinderschuhen nämlich in den
Schulen und Kitas in Deutschland im
Sommer habe ich am Tag der kleinen
Forscher in Hamburg mit Kita-Kindern
physikalische und chemische Experimente
gemacht es klingt jetzt erstmal groß
aber wir haben im Prinzip Öl und Wasser
miteinander vermischt und die
phasenbildung beobachtet haben Bindfäden
mit Salz an Eiswürfel geklebt und die
dann hoch gehoben aber so lernen die
Kleinsten spielerisch
Naturwissenschaften kennen und die
Begeisterung für Forschung und mit dem
mintaktionsplan oder Jugend forscht da
fördern wir die Kreativität und den
Einfallsreichtum von Schülerinnen und
Schülern und so setzen wir die
Rahmenbedingungen für starke
Wissenschaft und Zukunft heute und in
Zukunft
vielen Dank Ria Schröder war das für die
Liberalen und damit kommen wir zum
letzten Redner in dieser Debatte das ist
Holger Mann für die Sozialdemokraten im
Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren zunächst einmal
sei gesagt wir Sozialdemokraten begrüßen
dass nun auch die Union mit Blick auf
das Ziel der Klimaneutralität bis 2045
von einer unerlässlichen und großen
Transformation spricht das ist gut so
denn es war ja nicht immer so
nach Lesen ihres Antrags von CDU und CSU
und auch der Debatte stellen sich
zahlreiche Fragen die erste ist wofür
stehen denn ihre neuen Energie sie
bemühen diesen Terminus ja nicht nur an
der Überschrift wollen sie damit den
BürgerInnen mit dieser Wortschöpfung
Hoffnung machen dass die Lösung der
aktuellen Energiekrise einfach sei nach
dem motto-technologie löst alles das
hielte ich gerade in der aktuellen
Situation für Grund falsch
[Applaus]
oder aber meinen sie damit neue
energieerzeugungsformen falls ja findet
sich auf der letzten Seite ihres Antrags
einzig die konkrete Forderung neue
Ansätze der Kernfusion trägheitsfusion
zu fördern hier sei aber zumindest mal
gesagt der im Prinzip ist alles andere
als neu es ist seit der Entwicklung der
Wasserstoffbombe bekannt und wird seit
Dekaden erforscht in den USA sind seit
den 70er Jahren allein drei
großforschungsanlagen zur
thermoluklearen Kernfusion das meinte
sehr für zweistellige Milliardenbeträge
errichtet wurden Zeitpläne wie
Ergebnisse blieben leider weit hinter
den Erwartungen zurück und auch die
Fertigstellung der europäischen Anlage
bei Bordeaux ist inzwischen um mehr als
zehn Jahre in Verzug und beim Budget
jenseits von Gut und Böse deshalb sei
hier zumindest Zweifel angemeldet ich
finde umso erstaunlicher wie viele
Fürsprecher dieser psychologieansatz
gerade wiederfindet offensichtlich
hoffen immer noch viele darauf die
unerschöpfliche fossile Energiequelle zu
finden ich prognostiziere mit dem ersten
Hauptsatz der Thermomix Thermodynamik
das Perpetuum Mobile wird o2p bleiben
vielleicht erinnern wir uns genau
deshalb daran dass Sonne Wind Ressourcen
bieten die für die existenzzeit der
Menschheit völlig ausreichend sind zur
zweiten Frage warum soll ausgerechnet
die Wissenschaft die Komplettlösung für
die Energiefrage bringen und damit meine
Damen und Herren meine ich mitnichten
dass die Wissenschaft keine Ideen und
Expertise hätte nein im Gegenteil sie
hat diese bereits mannigfaltig geliefert
das Problem ist es gab wohl nirgends ein
so krasses Auseinanderfallen von
Expertise und politischen Handeln wie in
der Klima- und Energiepolitik und die
gibt es in Teilen dieses Parlaments bis
heute
obwohl die Wissenschaft seit Jahren vor
der globalen Erwärmung und zu hohem
Ausstoß durch fossile Energieträger
Waren werden in meinem Bundesland
Sachsen in den letzten Jahren
Windkraftanlagen zurückgebaut dort wie
in vielen unionsgeführten Bundesländern
hat man sich der Realität verweigert und
das Schwert den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien mit Abstandsregeln und weiteren
verboten kurz oben meine Damen und
Herren nein wir müssen jetzt in die
Umsetzung der Expertise der Wissenschaft
kommen und zwar auf allen Ebenen
zur dritten Frage braucht es jetzt
wirklich noch eine Strategie seit 2006
gibt es die Hightech-Strategie die 2007
zur Hightech-Strategie zum Klimaschutz
erweitert wurde 2010 folgte dann die
heizungsstrategie 2020 2014 die nächste
Haltestelle zu dem 2016 die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie in den letzten
Koalition haben wir gemeinsam die
haltestrategie 2025 und eine
wassersportstrategie auf den Weg
gebracht erinnert meine Damen und Herren
sei deshalb daran dass die Union damals
nicht nur Herrn Altmaier stellte sondern
alle Minister von Wissenschaft
Wirtschaft und Energie über Verkehr
Digitalisierung Inneres und Bau und jede
Möglichkeit hatte die Transformation
voranzubringen die sie uns heute mit
diesem Antrag einfordern
aber gut zurück zur strategiefrage just
heute ist nicht nur die Eröffnung der
fünften Jahreszeit sondern auch Stichtag
für die ressortrückmeldung zum Entwurf
der Zukunftsstrategie Forschung und
Innovation in deren erster vierter und
zweiten Mission sind die von Ihnen
genannten Themen und Herausforderungen
klar adressiert die Sammlung von Zielen
ist jetzt schon sehr ambitioniert wir
brauchen deshalb keine weitere
mieterstrategie sondern es braucht
Fokussierung Vereinbarungen zu
gemeinsamen Zielen und vor allen Dingen
deren Umsetzung vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Mann damit
schließe ich die Aussprache
in der fraktionell wird Überweisung der
Vorlage auf Drucksache 4315 an die in
der Tagesordnung aufgeführten Ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen